good evening and welcome to a special
edition of tucker carlson tonight
in july of 2017 every member of the
joint chiefs of staff met with newly
elected president donald trump for the
first time it didn't go well
you're all losers the president's told
them according to a foreign policy
magazine account you don't know how to
win anymore
now that's a harsh assessment obviously
though arguably true but the joint
chiefs of staff are keep in mind the
country's highest ranking military
officers their job is to follow the
orders of elected officials and protect
the country no matter how much their
feelings may be hurt
but in this case
that's not what happened because the
rules are different now
according to u.s army major general paul
eaton the president's insults that day
and similar comments he made in public
were a bitter humiliation for the
country's military leaders and they made
it their mission to undermine civilian
control of the pentagon
ever after quote i was really shocked by
how many of my former colleagues voted
for the former president and openly
supported him eaton said but when trump
turned on the military well
the military turned on him end quote now
keep in mind that's not how democracy is
supposed to work military leaders report
to the people you elect
but again that's not what happened
stories began leaking about how the
president president trump was ignoring
classified intelligence about russian
bounties in afghanistan where do you
think those stories came from they came
from the pentagon that was payback then
the military simply refused to withdraw
troops from syria and afghanistan even
though they were ordered to do so by the
elected president of the united states
again no more civilian control of the
military
when joe biden finally became president
on inauguration day the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff mark milley was so
excited he couldn't control himself
quote no one has a bigger smile today
than i do millie told michelle obama
sucking up like a child you can't see it
under my mask but i do
the media people who supported biden
from the very beginning
including a former cia director there
are many of those on television these
days also celebrated they told us that
the adults were back in charge the
orange man is gone
everything is going to be better now
anybody who has any
connection to reality
about what is going on around them
should have watched that and said the
adults are back in the room it seems as
though we have a
a professional adult once again in the
white house who's just simply doing the
work really the the theme i would say is
the adults are back still it is a relief
to have adults in charge now we have
adults in the white house okay the
adults are back in the room
there is a sense i think the world over
that the adults have returned we have an
adult in the white house now
and it's glorious
those clips are amazing to watch now
simply because they consist of the most
childish people in the country
celebrating adulthood but they look
especially absurd in light of what we've
just seen in afghanistan
these days joe biden's friends in the
pentagon and the foreign affairs desk at
nbc news no longer think he's an adult
he abandoned american citizens he got 13
americans killed and suddenly they seem
a little ashamed plus he's turned his
back on the neocon project and that's
the greatest defense of all
but the bigger question is why our media
and the military were talking like this
in the first place the adults are back
in charge what does that mean exactly
well if you follow the generals who've
been telling us for the past 20 years
about afghanistan you realize very
quickly adults means people who are
willing to pretend that everything is
fine when it's very much not fine
consider that no matter how badly our
mission in afghanistan was deteriorating
by the way we were never clear what that
mission was but clearly our strategy of
pacifying the country was falling apart
no matter how badly it got in
afghanistan the pentagon and its many
spokesman repeatedly told us we were
making incredible progress and progress
is the word they used again again and
again almost as if they coordinated it
in 2005 for example the head of u.s
central command general john abazad told
reporters quote over the three years
we've been operating here afghanistan
has shown interesting progress
two years later the website task and
purpose reported that another senior
general dan mcneil had a similar message
he said quote i'd like to point out
there is significant progress in the
forward move of the afghan national army
in 2008 the commander the 101st airborne
apparently another adult concurred that
progress was ongoing quote we're making
some steady progress here
then in 2010 even as coalition
casualties were increasing the progress
somehow continued to unabate it it was
progress no matter what a normal
lieutenant general called david
rodriguez informed reporters at a news
conference in kabul quote we are
steadily making deliberate can you guess
progress
that same year stanley mcchrystal then
the commander of all u.s forces in
afghanistan
also wanted us to know progress was
being made quote i think we have made
significant progress in saying the
conditions in 2009 and beginning some
progress and we'll make real progress in
2010
which we remind you was 11 years ago
then stanley mcchrystal was fired for
criticizing the obama administration in
particular the total incompetence of the
current president joe biden and david
petraeus took over and sure enough
general petraeus quickly declared that
quote progress has been achieved in some
critical areas and we are poised to
realize more progress
just a year later in 2011 petraeus
doubled down he told lawmakers that year
that the past eight months have seen
important but hard-fought progress
speaking that summer to troops in
kandahar the defense secretary at the
time robert gates echoed that theme
and what you've accomplished
uh is extraordinary because over the
last year essentially you have ejected
the taliban from their uh from their
home territory
and if we can hold this territory and
expand the bubble
then i think
i think by the end of the year we can
turn the corner in this conflict
gates didn't actually use the word
progress
he had more original language than that
but the message was the same and just to
make sure that message was crystal clear
senior military leaders kept
using that word a few years later the
chairman of the joint chiefs general
joseph dunford confirmed that progress
was indeed continuing quote at this
point we've made significant progress he
said that in 2013 and then three years
later in 2016 the new commander in
afghanistan john w nicholson said the
same thing we are seeing some progress
as recently as last year a spokesman for
mark milley said he was hard at work
making sure to accelerate progress in
afghanistan so if you're wondering why
americans were so confused by the fact
that kabul fell in an afternoon and the
taliban controlled the country that we
occupied for 20 years maybe it's because
they thought we were making progress
so consider that whole chronology you
just heard consider the news that
reuters broke this week about joe
biden's recent conversation with the guy
that we installed as the president of
afghanistan some college professor
called ashraf ghani
joe biden told gani that even as the
taliban were taking over the country
this summer the most important thing to
do is to keep up the appearance of you
guessed it progress
quote i need not tell you the perception
around the world and in parts of
afghanistan i believe is that things are
not going well in terms of the fight
against the taliban president biden said
and there is a need whether it is true
or not there is a need to project a
different picture
end quote
now two things to say about this first
we know that conversation took place
because the pentagon and or the state
department leaked it to reuters now why
would they do that
because whatever biden's faults he did
pull american troops out of afghanistan
and they hate that so they leaked an
audio tape of the president speaking to
another head of state that's illegal you
can't conduct statecraft if people are
leaking the contents of your
conversations
and yet they're doing that to get back
at him because he broke the rules he
stopped permanent war he did it ineptly
but he did it
so lying to the rest of us about what is
actually happening with our troops and
our money in our name in foreign
countries that has been the philosophy
of this country's military establishment
for 20 years it's also the philosophy of
every high-ranking official in the biden
administration
project the illusion of progress even
when it's clear we're failing tony
blanken who runs the state department
ineptly just announced the news
that more than a hundred american
citizens remain trapped in afghanistan
really kind of progressed
now
u.s military flights have ended
and our troops have departed afghanistan
a new chapter of america's engagement
with afghanistan has begun we believe
there are still a small number of
americans
under 200
and likely closer to 100
who remain in afghanistan and want to
leave
we're trying to determine exactly how
many
we had 20 years to figure it out but we
have no idea how many americans
including school children remain in
afghanistan because we're the adults in
the room and that's why we're going to
lead with our diplomacy now what does
that look like exactly how do you lead
with diplomacy well here's one example
back in april of this year tony blinken
state department announced that it was
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
in social programs in afghanistan to
destroy the patriarchy because that's
really our goal
impose our modernist social values on
prehistoric countries we're going to pay
for programs that support women's
empowerment
would that money go well to people like
dr bahar jalali who just posted this
dirge for equity in afghanistan on
social media quote for 8.5 years i
taught at the american university of
afghanistan as a faculty member and
academic administrator she wrote i
founded the first gender studies program
in afghanistan's history there all our
work hopes dreams progress only to have
it snatched away so needlessly
so you got to think it takes a special
kind of arrogance we used to call this
cultural imperialism to imagine that
other cultures want to ape your family
structure for example isn't it up to the
afghans what kind of families they want
no
we tried to impose our
customs on them and they hated it maybe
that's one of the reasons the taliban
took over in a weekend we hired people
like bihar jalali and ashraf ghani
to lead with our diplomacy that's what
afghanistan looked like for the past 20
years meanwhile we've been leading with
our diplomacy we've given billions of
american military
dollars with equipment to the taliban
row upon row of sophisticated assault
rifles boxes of pistols ammunition
vision equipment videos posted by the
taliban online in recent days boast of
what they say are their seizures of the
assault rifles in the afghan city of
herat and at kunduz airport armored
humvees by the dozen some mine resistant
ambush protected vehicles called mraps
costing half a million dollars a piece
even a small drone
these are the potentially lethal spoils
the taliban are believed to have
captured in recent days from defeated
afghan forces weapons made in america
supplied by the u.s to their fallen
afghan allies
so now we're arming the taliban and
we're ruining our own citizens in
afghanistan who could possibly have seen
that coming hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else